I submitted a question last week regarding the metastatic prostate cancer with my PSA being 0.1 and
antigen deprivation drugs being used. I do still have my prostate and did check out your blog post
on this. You already have me on TV. Go see TV. Go as a great TX track. That's a real clean T3 TX track.
What does that do? It helps decrease the intermoocant 6 levels, which is really important for
everybody, but it's even more important if you're on loop run for prostate cancer,
prostate clear for other things for the prostate clinic cancer, mushrooms, corsets, and tumeric
tumeric and corsets, and both help that intermoocant 6 as well, clear amino pack. What else do I need
from that blog post? You need adrographis. The clear of this amino mod A is a great source of
adrographis. Four of these a day will give you 250 milligrams of adrographis, and I highly suggest
just like as many as much as you can do with your other supplements is to break it into doses.
So if you can break it into four, you don't take one in the morning when you wake up one in
a new time, what a four o'clock in one before you go to bed there to even be the best. So a lot of
studies and adrographis with the prolonged the benefits of energy deprivation therapy.
I highly recommend that. This also has just some other anti-inflammatories and it's a really good
thing to calm the inflammation, and this is like a perfect supplement for anybody doing that.